Welcome to mCoding,
where we try to getjust a little
bit better at programming every episode
so that we can have an excuse for
writing on the window with dry erase markers.
I'm James Murphy, available
for Pythonconsulting.
Check me out at mcoding.io.
There's one feature of Python
that hasnot aged well.
So poorly in fact that even Python's
creator, Guido van Rossum,
wishesthat it was
never added to the language.
That feature is the `else` clause
of `for` and`while` loops.
Unlike `if-else`, `for-else` and `while-else`
are very uncommonly used.
Honestly,comment now if
you've never heard of these before.
So first off, what does
this`else` clause actually do?
The `else` clause of a `for` or `while` is
triggered after the loop terminates normally,
meaning without a break or exception.
So inboth of these cases,
it'll print 0, 1, 2, "DONE".
Whereas in either of these cases, it'll
just print 0, 1 and then it will not print "DONE".
Also, if there are no elements
to loop over,
this is still considered a normal end
of the `for` or `while` loop.
So, the `else` willstill be
executed in both of these cases.
By now I hope that you're asking
yourself something along the lines of:
"Okay... why is this called else?"
I mean,if something else something
makes sense.
For something else something or while something
else something...
What does that really mean?
And why does it correspond to this behavior
ofexecuting if there was no break or exception?
Way back in the day, Python was
much lesspopular.
And it was not expected to be the
only programming language that you knew.
It wasbasically understood that anyone
using Python was already familiar with C or C++.
And in particularhow compilers
implemented while loops in C/C++.
In C and C++, a while-loop could
just be implemented in terms ofan if check
with the same corresponding
condition and a go-to statement.
You label just before the start of the loop,
evaluate the condition.
Run the body of the loop and then
go back to the start to repeat the loop.
So believe it or not, the `else` in
Python's `while-else` is actually this `else`
in the if-go-to implementation
of a while-loop.
If there was a break in the while-loop,
that would correspond to a go-to to
the corresponding end label.
At the time it was expected
thatthis would be intuitive to users.
That idea obviously didn't
age that well.
But likeit or not in modern Python
that is what it means.
And likewise, the `else` in `for-else`
was meant for consistency with while.
Alternatively you could think about it in terms
of how `for`s are implemented in terms of `while`s.
So there's the first annoyance.
The modern Pythonprogrammer doesn't really
think about for and while loops in terms of go-to's.
Python doesn'teven have
a go-to that's accessible to you!
There was at some point some discussion
that maybe it should just be called
no-break instead of else.
This is clearerand more in
line with what it does.
So there'd be way less confusion
around it.
Butat this point, we can't
really change the else.
For reasons we're about to talk about you
shouldn't really be using this anyway.
But if you do choose to use
the else clause,
at the very least, include a comment
to help jog the reader's memory.
So theoretically, when might
youactually be tempted to use this?
The most common situation
thatI see is to avoid
a single extra "unnecessary"
flag variable.
Here we have a
simple index implementation.
index takes in a sequence like a list
and a target valueand tells you
where in the list that value is at what index.
We create a found flag to tellus
whether or not we've found the target element.
then we loop over the sequence.
If we findthe value, then
we set found to true and break.
Then at the end we either raise or return the
index that we found the element at.
The value of found at the end of the loop is always equal
to whether or not we broke out of the loop.
Since we can detect whether
we broke out of loopusing a for-else,
we technically don't need the
found variable.
Not found. Is just when
we broke out of the loop normally.
So we can just use else.
Cleaner and simpler, right?
Well, simpler than that other
implementation.
Aut why don't we just take this return.
And put it right where the break is?
Then we don't need an else at all.
And this is the second major reason why
for-else and while-else have aged so poorly.
The vast majority of the time, you can
get rid of a for-else or while-else just by refactoring.
Take your loop that you're going
to break out of.
Pull it out into a function like
what we have here.
And replace breaks with returns.
Of course, it's not always possible.
I know you can probably come
up with something.
But in the vast majority of cases,
it is possible.
And it's the same story for
the while-else.
You know, writing this example, I actually
realized how little I actually use while-loops.
I pretty much always think in terms of containers and iterables
and things that you use with for-loops.
Okay, so here's the situation.
Besides while-true which I do use that a while-loop
is actually better suited than a for-loop.
I start out at some time and want
to do work for five seconds.
While the current time is less than the target time,
I do some work and then I sleep for a little bit.
Let's just suppose that at some time
there's a possibility of some random error occurring.
Not an exception, just some way
of detecting that an error has happened.
We break out of the loop
if an error occurs.
And once again we use a flag to keep
track of whether or not we broke out of the loop.
Then we can either handle the error
or print out a "DONE" message.
If we run it, we see
working, working, working, working.
And then after three seconds,
we hit an error and handle the error.
Once again, theoretically this error
flag is unnecessary.
And we can get rid of it using
a while-else.
We do that like this.
If there was no break, that
means no error.
So, we just print our done message
and return.
If there was a break, then we skip
the return and handle the error.
Personally, I think this is way less readable.
I would prefer to just have the error flag.
All this is done in the name
of performance.
But this is going to be a huge readability
cost for what extra performance.
Really! Saving one extra boolean?
The performance benefit is going to be
minuscule at best if you can even measure it.
The only time something like this
could make a difference
is if you were doing it inside
of a hot loop.
And even then the savings are
still going to be less than a percent.
So please join me in actively avoiding
for-else and while-else.
Personally, I rarely see for-else
actually used.
And I have not once ever seen
while-else used in production code.
Although even the creator of Python
thinks that it was a bad idea
that it was ever put into
the language in the first place.
It's probably never going
to be removed.
That would be a major backwards
incompatibility requiring a Python 4-0 release.
From the Python 2 to Python 3 transition,
the Python community already
learned how much of a hassle this is.
So in the future, it's unlikely that
it'll get removed.
But there are still some things
that I would recommend for you.
Of course stop using it. And tell
your friends and coworkers to stop using it.
And politely suggest your DevOps
or Python infrastructure team
to either turn on or create a linter
rule to prevent you from doing this.
If you'd like to hear more about creating
your own linter rules, check out my video on the topic.
And finally, I just want to say
that all this bad stuff about `else`s
is only for for-else and while-else.
I have nothing against if-else
or try-except-else.
In fact, I think try-except-else is
actually very underutilized.
Anyway, and as always thank
you for watching!
Don't forget to like the video, comment
and subscribe for more Python content!
Special thanks to my patrons and
donors for supporting me!
I really appreciate the support!
If you especially like my content,
please consider becoming
a patron or donor! 😊